[Music]
[Music]
i want to point out first
happy to be here
[Music]
let's all go to the merch shop
let's all go to the murder shop
let's all go to the merch shop and
some sway
beautiful snazzy clothing and swag to
buy at crowdershop.com
like this new signature baseball tee
or these hoodies or of course the holy
grail itself mug club let's all go to
the merch shop
buy ourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is
hmm
wonderful that's the sound of the
morning that's the sound of a kind of
it's kind of a it's a basically a late
show in the morning and that's your
fault it's your fault because we used to
do this at night live and then we
realized like 90 of the audience you
guys would tune in in the morning huh
early birds so it makes sense why uh
colbert is dead so that's why i have to
get up so early that's why you have to
get upset oh man uh we have a lot that
we'll be talking about today new
election poll that just came out as far
as how many amer and i think we're
allowed to talk about this on youtube
because it's a verified poll it's a
whole rcp average it's not worth saying
that a majority of americans think joe
biden won due to cheating but the
democrat number is what will surprise
you
i mean if anything there's a little bit
of unity on us
finally we found the we did bridge the
great divide yeah that's a good thing so
i want to talk about that a little bit
and i want to talk about how this is
really designed to make you think that
you're crazy right everything's removed
from every uh every platform available
right now if you even discuss it and the
truth is that 56 of americans think that
something went on not saying that that
can be verified or not right now that's
not what we're doing in this show what i
am saying is for everybody else to
decide that it's a coup for you to
believe what most americans believe you
are not alone and we'll get into why
that is also columbus wasn't a rapist
genocidal maniac i know we're not
supposed to say that but everyone was
bitching about it yesterday and i said
he is no no no
1492 columbus made the [ __ ] black and
blue he did
he did i didn't know that part it was
black columbus moan that was the second
verse that's the that's the detroit
version
that's what we learned yeah
we talked about that and something about
a racist football coach who may not
actually be racist
so let me introduce gerald a that's the
voice you're here how are you sir i am
well sir how are you ah you know i'm
okay i did it too on purpose i'm in a
bad mood today and you guys will find
out why later because of gerald it was
my fault uh we're going to watch we're
going to review the fouchy documentary
on mug club now you've given up the
wreath yeah you did it that's called
foreshadowing i'm your call me your
steinbeck uh
quarterback garrett good morning how are
you going on let's go brandon prayers
keep him in your prayers to avoid the
sickle cell he doesn't have it more of a
preventative prayer and dave landau ahoy
brandon
and uh you'll be at the improv in
orlando this weekend yes friday and
saturday uh i have three different plane
tickets to hope i get there i'm not even
kidding roll the dice on the plane
you know it's bad when one of your your
fallback is spirit it is it's your
safety airline thank god i had points
yes all right really quickly before
we're going to talk about uh the
football coach really but they're
talking about him on cnn right now let's
let's uh what's his name again there joe
you're the one john gruden las vegas
raiders coach that looks like i don't
know 10 years ago he said stuff yes yeah
it literally yeah here's how
former nfl and hall of fame wide
receiver i should know randy moss what
he had to say about green i want to get
your reaction look hey look we're gonna
hey someone else said this can i get
your reaction about what someone else
said about an email that i won't cover
live on air i'll just say racist and
homophobic and sexist but the guy
responded to it can you respond to him
uh uh is this news we say it is that's
why we label it
john madden to highlight the racist
words he used i'm sorry
he's talking about the clock ticking
shut up randy moss you ran over a lady
in minneapolis and got away with it yeah
that's true yeah i don't follow sports i
want to hear what this guy's to say
though but if you know his history you
know that when he was in high school um
he had a situation with a fight that
took place in school he went from being
basically the biggest star in west
virginia to being a pariah and i've
always imagined that in that time he
probably learned that a lot of white
people that thought that he was the
bee's knees when he was catching that
football and all of a sudden he wasn't
going to the university of west virginia
and he wasn't playing for his high
school i imagine he heard a lot of
things from a lot of people that he
thought were cool in the first place and
i think that's what's happening with
john gruden for a lot of people is his
argument that there was a black guy who
was popular and then he wasn't popular
and so therefore white people are racist
i don't get sports no what he's saying
now is like this is happening to john
gruden everybody loved john gruden and
now they find out the truth about john
gruden is what it seems like are they
saying john they loved john gruden in
high school no that was randy moss yeah
it was about randy moss that's what i'm
saying but he's trying to say that randy
moss realized that white people liked
him when he was winning and then they
weren't like look that's just it's
called sports have any of you heard from
jerry cooney recently
who who heared my point exactly hardest
hitter in arguably all of boxing two
guys ernie shavers jerry cooney jerry
cooney is the hardest hitter possibly in
the history of boxing and ernie shavers
and you don't know who they are why
because when they stop winning people
don't pay jerry cooney's white by the
way just so you know it's not a race
thing it's no it's only as valuable as
your last performance it was drago i saw
him hit the bag and it registered like
the high number yes and then the
yes
all right well you know what let's go
let's let's go to this quickly then
we'll go to kamala harris afterwards
since they're talking about this on can
i just say
i'm just i'm stunned that a uh a coach
is a dick yes i think we all should be
just so surprised well i want to hear
you guys you know comment comment below
in what you've read about this because
it was really hard for me to find the
original emails and the original
pejoratives and i always look at it look
whenever you hear a blanket statement of
sexist racist homophobic red flag goes
up right away why because if the guy for
example said the edward that would be
the lead it would say yeah
gudgeon kujin what's his name kuden
gruden
it would say gruden said the n word
right right away if they're saying
homophobic like well hold on what does
that mean he said
he said i'm terrified of homosexuals
what are you honestly let's break down
that language i don't i've never known
anyone in my life who's afraid of
homosexuals i know what you try and do
you're trying to say that anyone who
disagrees with any certain sexual
activities whether heterosexual
homosexual bigamists that somehow
they're afraid of it i get it like
transphobia if i don't think that a 45
year old man should be able to take a
dump in the junior high school girls
locker room i'm transphobic i understand
it the point is when you see these
blanket words out there right away your
[ __ ] meter should go
okay so let's get down to what was
actually said um
in the emails from the new york times
what they quote they reported yeah they
say that he called roger goodell a uh
the uh
uh a a uh a fat and then followed by
good affair and by the way i don't know
because i don't want to give it the the
honor of calling it the f word because
there's only one and i hold it in high
esteem
it's very useful it's very descriptive i
just can't say it on youtube and uh the
other homophobic comment he made was he
called somebody a clueless anti-football
[ __ ]
okay well that's straightforward you
called someone a woman yeah yeah by the
way why do i know roger goodell's name
why is that familiar commissioner of the
nfl i know but wasn't there something
with him in trouble yes well of course
he's been in trouble several times what
was his thing well he most recently he
was the one kind of cowing to the blm
protest right stuff yeah and he was
accused of being racist as well well
before that yeah before that he was
accused of being racist my point is so
now why are we shouldn't you be glad
that someone said something misogynistic
about the guy you said was racist yeah
look at that nfl civil war the the the
the deskers let them just fight it out
hey it's a it's a chauvinist fighting a
racist you don't believe any of this
that's my point
i assume that the f word and [ __ ] is
usually what coach has called you just
based on any sport i've ever played yes
me too yeah much yeah my my dad put it
on my jersey yes
my dad has it reserved for my headstone
yeah oh wow jeez
fat and then get yeah
i was like why did you do that by the
way you isn't why would you want to
outlive your son that's weird yeah are
you going to garner the real problem is
i can't do in a jewish cemetery because
of the mickey mouse tattoo i have in my
ass no no i just
i just hope
[Laughter]
i i just what do they call
[Laughter]
100 feet from the cemetery
imagine that guy who's jewish can't be
buried there then he can't be buried in
an asian cemetery because he finds out
that what's written is something
incredibly anti-japanese it's
ethnocentric but it looked cool japanese
handwriting okay uh so
apparently that uh apparently this
gruden character also said goodell
should not have pressured former rams
coach jeff fisher to quote draft queers
in reference to michael sam
apparently he so look he criticized
president obama during his re-election
campaign referred to joe biden as a
nervous clueless [ __ ] look this is a
perfect example and that last one was
right yeah no none of this is not
nothing that i have read here is that is
is offensive or fireable no to be clear
like
really are we gonna all this is the
issue is people it's not that people are
hypocrites because i'm a christian and i
just quoted words that you'd like okay
well you shouldn't say those words and i
understand it right but i am quoting
this the point is everyone's a hypocrite
but if people out there act as though
they are so offended at the same oh
he called someone a [ __ ] i'm why i
never no yes you would ever and you have
okay let's stop acting like we've never
called someone a clueless [ __ ] right
and matt damon again found out five
minutes ago apparently that this was a
bad word to say one of the words he said
and nobody canceled matt damon for it
they were they tried to pissed off they
should have canceled him for all the
pretty horses no i mean basically they
had to win a few times and let him
continue on it's like all right we'll
just make this like a good show we'll be
pissed at you and then you'll come and
do movies again what you couldn't
possibly wait is it all the pretty
horses or is it horse whisperer i don't
know which one was which one was matt
damon um
they're both awful it's gotta be all the
pretty horses right i think it's all the
pretty horses i don't know i don't know
we bought a zoo it is no that's another
one
not to be confused with zookeeper which
is paramount or zootopia yes and there's
a the tiny movie like i was saying where
he becomes little and he lives in a
little place oh yes that's right yeah
and it sucked he's made a lot of awful
awful he's made a lot of and good will
hunting is crap you're all wrong no it's
good it's a garden with you let me
his name is will hunting
in the movie
and the name of the movie is good will
hunting good it's the shittiest thing
i'm sorry pardon my language okay good
will hunting is the latest movie
yeah what if his name was my name is i
can see your lips from here
it is all the pretty horses it's all the
fruity horses thank you i'm glad that we
put our research team together
right now they're all back there look at
stephen's gonna steven's gonna beat me
if i don't find all the pretty horses
that's fair that's a fair point like
bobby knight as a coach just yelled
[ __ ] over and over again sword
that old snl sketch where it's the chess
coach and he's just launching chairs
that was dick butkus's breathing
exercise it was breathe in count four
breathe out and [ __ ]
okay the point is this is when people
got mad about it donald look the donald
trump situation i said what what i'm mad
about is he talking about someone else's
wife
not that he talked about what someone
would consensually allow you to do
grabbing their nether regions okay the
point here is there are conversations
that aren't meant to be broadcast to the
entire world and sometimes sometimes
things that you wouldn't say for example
to the press or things you wouldn't say
i don't know at a thanksgiving table are
entirely appropriate when you are trying
to motivate a team full of killers
exactly
you basically found serial killers and
gave them a creative outlet
[Laughter]
it's just people that hurt people yes
and they get paid to do it well yeah
that's it and and so look before these
most recent emails came out there was
another controversy from emails before
which i will say i remember very recent
though it was pretty recent but he
didn't get fired for this he got fired
for his recent comments uh meaning from
yesterday or this morning i don't know
exactly depending when you're watching
this broadcast the prior emails leaked
he said uh demoris smith has lips the
size of michelin towers so that
that tires yes that seems
i mean on it's on the surface it kind of
you could say that but i've never heard
of somebody referring to a black man's
lips as tires in in a racist context
i've never heard that before period
right i could see though how for a
racist it would be apt yes no i
definitely understand so here's here's
the thing context always matters right
so you've got black players because
obviously in the nfl there are black
players on the teams
years and years and years in the past
tim brown from notre dame played for the
raiders played for john gruden came out
and said i've never heard him say
anything racist i've never heard him
lean towards saying anything racist this
is absolute crap john gruden came out
and said look this was happening when
the nfl was threatening to strike and i
was sending pissed off emails because
they were trying to take away people's
livelihoods they were trying to take
away what everybody cared about and i
was pissed and i said this guy the
dombro smith i think he was like the
nflpa representative or something like
that and he said this guy is lying he
has lips the size of michelin tires he
can't spit it out i don't know i look i
don't know if i buy that and by the way
i don't think that's a fireable offense
and i guarantee that if you found the
guys talking about you could probably
find far more racist things that someone
else has said about him you know black
people say with white people right you
know i don't know what it is like we
smell like chicken all that kind of
stuff the point is everyone has a great
thing they say about each other yeah
right things just smell like mayo is
that what it is
we kiss our
[Applause]
my point is we get it and this is sports
right you're not trying to hire somebody
who's supposed to appease the most
amount of people you're trying to
involve people in an organization who
understand the audience and they
understand how to win a game exactly big
michelin dsl well that's right that
helps out as well but here's the the
broader point is that the nfl is
basically the buy a pair of michelin
tires
the nfl has basically got a no tolerance
point right now they they're not going
to tolerate any of this and and john
gruden what cte oh no they do tell us
later on when you kill your wife no yes
they're not going to tolerate anything
that costs them money yeah don't don't
say anything racist just you know bottle
it up and then eventually beat a chick
in an elevator
exactly just hit a woman so hard it
closes a casino hold on
i'm sorry dave he could still run the
football did that affect his
michael vick is just fine i just
wouldn't no it's terrible i wouldn't
have him run a dog sitting service
we'll watch a dog oh that looks like he
could fight michael vick's new doggie
day care right i don't think its ear was
bitten off when i dropped them off
remember when they accused white people
of being racist because they weren't
fond of michael vick you know getting
back in the spotlight oh wasn't that you
know it's the first rule of filmmaking
is don't kill the dog i don't think it's
so much i don't think it's so much that
michael vick was black if you want to
make it a racial thing i think it's that
he was drowning and electrocuting dogs
and he was doing it on such a massive
scale that he ran out of room i don't my
my primary gripe with michael vick and i
know we all have our own biases so maybe
i have a blind spot i don't think that
melanin was chief amongst them no but
stop breaking the law
but to his defense he was a ladies man
and electrocuting dogs was the only way
he could get an erection yes jesus
the fbi is like we have a page for this
wow this is it's called nature cialis
man
all natural toasters not nature yes
okay it's better than the rest of the
nfl after this where they get the cte
and they take that toaster into the tub
yeah well they can get the ripe old age
of 46
beating your porn you want these people
to go out and destroy their brains and
their bodies right you want them to go
out like animals and warriors and when i
say animals i mean the white guys too
meaning the guys in the referee uniforms
i mean you want them all to go out there
as savages and then you're mad it's just
like they said about you know churchill
churchill lost his lost re-election yeah
he was ousted do you know why this is
the man who single-handedly right
stopped the nazis from taking over
europe because he didn't want to support
socialized healthcare then he was
discarded wartime presidents are not
valued during times of peace you send
these guys out there it requires a screw
loose to get to that high of a level in
sports and subject yourself to that
amount of punishment or to be involved
with the sport and coach these killers
and then you want them to come back and
be the kinds of people who should teach
your sunday school class look you're not
going to find a lot of guys like that
out there and if you keep firing them
you're going to end up with a wnba with
weaves on the floor
no no it's slippery man you get millions
of dollars and then you die at 45 at
your car dealership that's the extreme
deal yes
he could have literally committed
robbery he could have had drunken
driving after drunken driving yeah he
could have done drugs and been caught
for that six or seven times alvin smith
i'm looking at you right all of these
things he could have done that other
players right now are still in the
league for doing and by the way again
randy moss ran over a woman trying to
give him a ticket
totally fine
randy boss ran somebody over and he know
at the time
[Laughter]
it's like come on you can commit any
other crime than being mean if you ran
someone over who's trying to get to keep
in mind everybody knows if you're
watching lady if you watch mug club you
know i don't know we play the game
steven i know nothing about sports and
we've gone on way too long with this
topic but because i'm fascinated at
learning about so he ran over someone
with his shirt was on the hood of his
car holding on yes she was a happy
gilmore dude
pretty much did they get out of the way
[ __ ] yeah she was giving him a parking
ticket i think is a story and he just
started driving off and she's like tried
to stop him was on the hood of his car
he drove down the street with her on the
hood of the car stopped let her get off
that's a meter maid who takes her job
way too seriously yeah it's just like
he didn't miss a game still though i
mean honestly you're a meter maid and
the guy's like i'm i'm going to drive
off you're like not on my watch this 22
ticket i'm gonna risk life and limb for
this yeah so a meter maid is like come
on that's one tenth of a person that was
two times damn it
no vikings fan cared at all because he
was like the most dominant receiver
nobody who's ever gotten a parking
ticket cared at all
they were like good he's gonna serve
right another win for randy
all right i'm kidding if you're a
parking meter later i'm sure yes you
have a wonderful job if you're a black
parking meter later if you're a white
parking if you're a white meter mate run
the [ __ ] over so um those aren't there
[Laughter]
uh
here's another story speaking of people
getting caught
kamala harris put out a series of
youtube videos and look i understand i
really want to get to the election yeah
uh new poll and the columbus myths but
this is just something we have to talk
about because
she's the vice president i mean kind of
president i guess
i don't even know what the terms are
anymore i don't either yeah some she's
in a cabinet somewhere
okay she's the harris in the cupboard
did she come out yesterday
she's the half
kamala in the cupboard
that the kid doesn't want
if it was if it was half kamala in the
cupboard that kid would that would be
the the dvd cover just open it up and
then close bananas
she'd be filled with syrup yeah he'd
call over the toy soldiers hello
gorgonauts yeah
i need you to off just no she's in my
cupboard i don't know half indian half
african-american she banged the mayor
what the hell is the difference get over
here my coverage stinks now
all right so over the weekend kamala
harris you're not my vice president uh
put out a series of youtube videos
candidly teaching children
about space because of course it gives
us a sense of
the magnitude of it all
earth is kind of small yes
right
the earth is like a speck
[Music]
of the sun that's what you said about
willie brown's donagher look at the
design of this man
people and the smart people and the
scientists and the engineers
came up with the idea that if you build
something that looks like that you can
see the sun like when you slept with a
mayor right
well wait till they see them i like how
you're not supposed to look at the sun
and they're testing it on earth
always dream with ambition
have big dreams
you'll remember that yes okay now i want
to get something after this an actual
point but uh she's so unlikable that
apparently they couldn't get children
alone in a room with her so these were
actually child actors and i don't mean
crisis actors they were paid child
actors really there was no they didn't
trust kamala harris to organically get
children interested wait this isn't a
bit no it's not a bit absolutely true no
it's not evident all the references are
available again louder with squadron.com
link in the description these are paid
child actors
wow the ones corey feldman yeah they
could have
hired some writers to have her say some
things that sounded smart she was just
like if they make a thing that looks
like this they didn't in other words
they didn't trust you're going to go out
there and impress children right they
didn't trust kamal they didn't trust an
organic reaction so they said let's make
sure we pay some kids union scale
they'll take care of it
somebody's holding up like applause
signs behind
and you wonder why we don't have trust
in our institutions look i get it and i
know that they're paid out and when you
but the truth is this is supposed to be
a reading rainbow you know don't take my
word for it type moment and instead we
end up with something that is fake
children are not interested in what she
has to say i don't even know if what
she's saying is true i just i assumed it
was true because the kids were agreeing
yeah she's like by the way dream big we
did we're child actors oh yeah is that
why you hopped on a san francisco mayor
who was also banging half the think
about this for a second think about this
for a second we tell young girls to not
be obsessed with their bodies right we
tell young girls and this is true that
you are more than your body that you
should use your brain that you have
other qualities that matter that you can
break through the glass ceiling if you
work hard that women absolutely all
these things that i support women should
be paid just as much as a man for the
same amount of work which they are now
the first lady and the first female
presidential candidate okay hillary
clinton and the first actual female vice
president are both famous for banging
rich guys
they both got their job by banging
powerful guys let's be clear about that
what kind of example is that sending out
to young and by the way just like elon
omar banging her brother kamal harris
doesn't even deny it
again just like if gruden said said the
n-word they would lead with that if
kamala harris said no way of course not
i didn't have a relationship with brett
there's no way brown was like i had a
lot of [ __ ] that was his response did
you guys really that was responsible i
had a lot of [ __ ] what do you want
who can keep track dream big as big as
montel williams junk yes
which i've had many times he sells
nutribullets now yes and then you have
hillary clinton everyone knows you can
go to people who went to college with it
was a relationship of convenience rod
got a broad got a time share in new york
state for four weeks became your senator
and you know what it was an airbnb
she's probably the only person who
didn't actually bang bill it's not lost
the sun is less of a ball of fire than
this planet yeah
all right okay we have to move on from
this uh i also have a question for you
guys how did you celebrate columbus day
yesterday i murdered an indian did you
very nice i got lost and then not a
native american i want to be clear yes
no to be clear an indian that was a
player for the indians ah yes uh and you
can subscribe by the way to the podcast
uh on on apple on spotify all of that
and uh live show monday through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern is when you can tune
in i'm just letting you know this
because uh you will get to it later you
cannot find this show if you search for
it you cannot
foot five with blonde hair and blue eyes
do i need to say anything more from a
tree house okay
so yesterday uh governor abbott
dreamboat
he banned vaccine mandates in the entire
state of texas yeah so
no entity in texas can compel receipt of
a coven 19 vaccination by any individual
including an employee or consumer who
objects to such vaccination for any
reason of personal conscience now keep
this in mind of course the left is
saying how dare they when the left and i
mean this is not what about ism but this
is important because remember the hobby
lobby story so right now all this is
saying is you cannot be compelled you
cannot be forced to take the vaccine and
by the way abbott said the vaccine is
safe and effective and people should use
it but it should be voluntary that's
what he said to be clear so leftists are
mad that he is blocking a mandate to
force you to get a vaccine they were
also furious that hobby lobby they were
demanding that hobby lobby be forced to
pay for not the 16 forms of birth
control that they covered but all 21.
hobby lobby was opposed to i'm going by
wrote either three or four firms of
forms of birth control they covered 16
because they believe these were
abortificans which took place after
fertilization right and the left said no
no we want to compel hobby lobby to
provide not 16 21 forms of birth control
and now they are appalled that you have
a governor blocking a mandate to take a
vaccine they want control over every
stay out of my bedroom
don't make me pay for it
right stay out of my arm i get to make
you should be free it's a it's a
pandemic of the unvaccinated you you're
gonna kill then let the republicans kill
off their voter base right exactly what
do you care oh that's right you're
frustrated because you took a vaccine
that sucks all right well he also said
look you have to take into account the
fact that people have had coveted and
recovered from it right just like they
do in other countries right so he he
didn't just say you could opt out of it
which is a huge win i mean i don't think
people understand how big of a deal that
is and i hope other governors follow
suit and do it by executive order do it
by something that can't be overturned by
the whims of people on the left or
challenge do it in a way that people can
depend on it because people right now
are expecting to get fired in the next
month and do it in a way that hurts
yeah with a big middle finger yeah do it
in a way that stings a little bit okay
they deserve that yeah um by the way
also while we're talking about this in
italy protests are going on
all over the country you guys may not be
paying attention to this the last thing
you heard of italy was when they had the
worst uh you know one of the worst death
rates in the world uh but now they're
having these green pass uh basically
vaccine passports coming into play and
the protests i mean it's not quite
australia but this is a big deal and
americans aren't talking about it here
what started off as a restless yet
peaceful protest
sparked a tinderbox as demonstrators
stormed the headquarters of italy's
biggest trade union some were
neo-fascists they shout freedom from a
national vaccine mandate starting next
weekend italians are required to show
proof of vaccination recovery or
negative covet test in order to enter
the workplace the strictest such law in
the world well it's not just enter the
workplace it's all museums theaters gyms
indoor restaurants uh trains buses any
domestic flights
so this is literally basically to live
in italy hot look when people when
you don't stop an italian from going to
the gym you don't stop in italian
jim you don't do that or to the uh the
wax or what are they called wax the the
esthetician beautician i don't know the
tanning place esthetician i don't know
the day go waxy we're gonna start taking
down statues of uh little kids with
angel wings taking a piss
cherubim i don't know
you know what i mean that's the thing
it's not quite bronze it's not quite uh
steel you know what i'm talking about
he likes it no look where's my chain how
can whenever whenever anyone says we
need to be more like europe um look
obviously you need to take stories and
countries you need to take them
individually yeah
but my blanket sentiment is no
yeah because immediately they've never
gotten it right musa lady wasn't that
long ago in the realm of human history
you're screwing up again italy and the
people realize it this is where you have
that divide it's the government doesn't
realize that they're sort of inching
towards that but the people are like oh
no we already have this and our guy was
the worst the one
he was mussolini was hitler mussolini
was hitler governor all those types of
guys just pol pot without the without
the ability right exactly he was a very
small guy he had to kill a lot more
people he didn't have to get control
yeah but i think they like none of them
respected him no they they was like yeah
mussolini yeah he'll partner
i mean they hung him at the end of the
war so yeah
so i i think they also misunderstand
fascism because they're like and some of
them are neo-fascists and chanting
freedom and i'm like i'm sorry what
that's the complete opposite of what
fascism is antifa doesn't understand
what fascism is and italians don't
understand it it's like come on guys
this was your whole raise on that yeah
no is that right i said well you said it
in french right yes yeah i know no no no
it is fascist doesn't everyone remember
hitler saying i want you to go out there
and make your voices heard and don't let
the ss control you you are your own
person be free
i do remember i have a tattooed on me
right think about this first no that's
the electrical company that's a
different thing yeah think about that
they've been wrong about it always
germany all world wars
yeah germany made some mistakes but
people when i say to people this is the
longest standing constitutional republic
democratic republican existence what do
you mean france had to retool everything
so did germany so did italy multiple
times since the united states inception
sure we've made corrections but we still
have the same system of government why
because it relies on self-governance and
the freedom of the individual before the
rights of intrusion of the state that's
why we're standing the longest people
and it's ironic because you go to europe
and everything's older and crappier mind
you but the truth is people go to europe
to look at the beautiful things that
were right you go on a tour and it's fun
to visit and it's the same way in
montreal where i'm from in a lot of ways
they come to america to be a part of the
beautiful thing that is okay and i don't
know why we'd want to go back to
the countries that cannot avoid
repeating history yeah well the same
crowd that is chanting let us be more
like europe actually came out with a
coveted policy that is more regressive
because in europe you just said it the
green pass that's the pretty much the
same thing they have in every other
country having a green pass not the same
rules for it right includes vaccinate
vaccination or recovering yeah the
united states does not recognize fauci
for some reason doesn't think that it
should be on that thing that says oh
i've had covenant recovered from it i
have antibodies yeah that's just 70
something million americans i think now
yeah so it doesn't get you anywhere and
europe at least recognizes i'm like guys
in this case i would love for you to be
like europe right even though generally
not by the way many european countries
they also don't have mass mandates for
children just to be clear wow people
don't understand that america is
actually what you know that's that's
true i mean that's just it's absolutely
true in the uk they don't they just
don't follow whl no they don't follow
the wwe i don't know why
it won't get fooled again
and we just got fooled again yeah and
that teenage mask land and they they
what if what if they tried to ban the
who
in taiwan but instead they banned the oh
no we banned the guess who oh
it's the worst problem ever we know
what's on your computer pete townsend
okay new poll rasmussen poll this is
huge
uh and people say well they're biased
okay let's say that rasmussen leans
slightly to the right they've been much
more accurate if you look at
presidential polls and a lot of their
state polling and accurate enough to be
included in the rcp average right the
data year after year so let's be clear
this is a legitimate poll certainly more
than nbc uh cnn msnbc when they say
these polls show that the vast majority
of americans and insert whatever it is
here so this one's pretty clear too
because i think it matters with how you
frame a question in a poll yeah you can
frame questions in
multiple different ways where you'll get
different answers this one is pretty
simple where people were asked that if
they thought that cheating played a
factor uh in joe biden winning the
presidency if it actually the exact
words are it's likely that cheating
affected the outcome of the 2020
election pretty clear do you agree with
that statement 56
of all likely voters
of all likely voters now that's
important because that's the metric
that's often used it's most accurate not
just registered voters not just the
population at large likely voters is
kind of the gold standard we can argue
that the point is it actually is
certainly one of the top two so 56
here's the crazy part to me
32 of democrats wow
you can't get 32 of democrats to agree
with republicans on nearly anything so
you will see this in the media and i was
watching cnn this morning this is this
is something that is incredible when you
think about it they say oh we have look
we have donald trump uh the big lie and
two-thirds of republicans believe the
big lie hold on a second a third of
democrats do that's a big deal
that's a huge a third of you guys
how does that happen even if i believe
that donald trump cheated to win the
election i wouldn't admit it in a poll
why just lie here's another thing that
that poll talked about it said 51
overall of all likely voters think that
having all mail-in ballots will increase
the likelihood of cheating happening in
the future yeah we've talked about all
of this mind you and we've had to talk
about it in such a way as not to be
removed from this platform
and now finally we can do we're quoting
a poll that's all we're doing this is a
poll right it's a poll not us so this is
a poll it's 56 of americans including a
third of democrats okay but what happens
if you type in joe biden cheated
into youtube or if you type in election
fraud or 2020 election into youtube hey
what happens if you type in we've
covered the election we covered it live
most watched live program of any program
that night in election night okay
what happens if you type in crowder oh
voter fraud what happens if you type in
steven crowder voter fraud you have to
scroll down 25 entries through some
videos that don't even have 10 000 plays
to get to the content of this channel
which has and you'll have videos that
have one two million plays but they're
very 25 searches down in other words
look the important thing that you need
to understand here is this is the media
people use the term gaslighting they
want you to think that you're crazy that
you're some minority that you're a
violent insurrectionist just because and
56 of you are saying
i think it played a factor i don't at
the very least you're not parroting the
line that they've told you to pair it
otherwise you know unless you lose your
accounts you're not parroting this was
the safest and most secure election in
our history maybe you didn't get the
talking points member you're still
paroding elizabeth warren bernie sanders
amy klobuchar for the last election the
point is we're glad to have you on the
team here's
better late than never they want you to
feel as though they're
there's no one else out there like you
that you are alone they want you to feel
like you're an extremist and you should
speak of these things in hushed tones if
you discuss this if you're one of the 56
percent of americans who discusses it
who posts about it on twitter on youtube
on facebook right that's 90 something
percent of information yeah that's
controlled in the united states if you
say if you express a sentiment that you
source by the way that you reference
you will be removed you and 56 percent
of americans yeah that's where we are
right now oh hold on chappelle's yeah
dave chappelle's back on they're they're
dave zappell oh look at this in quotes
dave chappelle says gender is a fact
during yeah okay let's see what snopes
says
i love that uh netflix by the way uh
suspended their employees for insulting
it good they tried to crash a meeting
yeah that's what it was yeah they tried
to crash from the meeting because they
were against uh the the show it's a
little bit of a hodgepodge i want to go
back to that i want to hear what this is
but it's awesome
says gender is a fact they put that in
quotes well the next yeah this one
several of them
it is defense transphobic jokes just no
defills well yeah it shouldn't say it
that way it's just saying that they are
transphobic but many people and also
glad
they strongly disagree with that
that's dead air that's scary someone a
lot of people strongly disagree with
that um
the dude in the middle looks like
somebody who wouldn't talk to his gay
son yes it was suspended
yes well erica so three employees who
worked for netflix have been suspended
according to a source
close to the situation who spoke to me
yesterday one of those individuals is a
woman named tara field and
there were some tweets criticizing this
special um and saying you know look i
work at netflix and i do not support
this this is hate speech and this goes
against the trans community um now
netflix though has released associations
saying that
this goes against the trans community
it's your employer
go away
go away bye bye find another job it's
like when they tried to boycott spotify
for bringing in joe rogan oh that was an
amazing thing yeah it's like you're
paying this guy 100 million dollars
they're paying you 40 grand a year which
one do you think they're gonna get rid
of and by the way they should be on
unemployment
they should be destitute and penniless
and it should sting they shouldn't get
bennies from the government because of a
pandemic i want to be clear about that
if you walk because of a dave chappelle
special yeah and you say i don't want
this at netflix well you didn't create
netflix you didn't invest into netflix
you don't care
about starting your own business you've
demanded security in place of glory
leave and you get you get nothing but
again this is the issue is cnn is acting
gender is a fact they want you to think
you're crazy they want enough of you to
watch this and go oh wait hold on a
second they put that in quotes
i i thought i believe gender's a fact no
no no hate speech no i don't want to say
that they say well hang on a second i
thought we kind of all knew that there
was some stuff that happened with the
election no no wait wait no it's 56
percent of americans and most americans
believe that if you are born with a
hanging a swinging a [ __ ] and balls
between your legs that you are a boy
okay that's most americans it's not
crazy it's not hateful doesn't mean that
you want to drag
drag a transgender behind your ford
pickup you can be nice empathetic and
also say you know what there's a reason
that every single doctor since the
beginning of time has had to agree to a
rule book it's so that i don't get
misdiagnosed as pregnant when i have
prostate cancer right i can't even get
the chips to buy the f-150 the drag i
don't know right transition it's hard to
do that whatever they're going to do you
don't want to do that anyway we're going
to be talking about columbus day myths
so we'll figure out how to get those
chips later i i oh i i know they're
building plants some of the companies i
hope so we need that but there so one
thing i need to point out too is that
you said 56 percent oh he meant computer
chips i was thinking casino chips okay i
was thinking that too well i was
thinking ladies bet you can't eat just
one i'm sorry i was out of it no there's
a big shipment of chips that are coming
from oh yeah yeah the cars are rotting
out on you new new cars right now cars
on lots because we can't get the cpu
yeah and chinese are laughing at us
right now so 56 right now this isn't
trending in their favor either it was i
think 56 for those who are just tuning
in who think that
who thinks cheating was involved that
joe biden won in part because of
cheating that's overall likely voters
over all those actually i think 51 in
april
so this is so it's gone up this isn't
trending in their favor by the way bring
that back up really quickly
i want to clarify one thing so you said
32 percent uh of democrats it's actually
of unaffiliated voters oh no no no
you're right at the bottom never mind
you're good no it's 32 percent of
democrats 54 of unaffiliated right
and uh it's so and only 39 don't think
it is that's insane so in other words
there is a lot more neutral or do think
it is than aggressively i don't think it
is yeah i didn't know if unaffiliated
like independent voters if they were
lumping those two together but then 32
percent is democratic 32 exclusively
registered democrats that's crazy sorry
okay i thought david's gonna go say
something all right
no i was uh just kind of shocked yeah
actually it wasn't it's just it's i
everybody knows this you know what
comment below to let people know that
you're not alone comment either gender
is a fact not in quotes
hello
or i'm part of the 56 percent i will
allow you to include
a middle finger emoji but no more i want
to keep these uniform so that people can
sign on the dotted line consider it a
petition gender is a fact or i am part
of the 56 i am not saying that i am or i
am not and you would never be able to
tell because you can't find the hours
and hours of content that are available
on youtube uh
t-shirt with that that says 56 plus
percent
like have a date yeah just make sure
it's not a three-piece rocker otherwise
you're gonna get in trouble in the wrong
way not to bring it back to the
beginning of the show but my my coaches
always felt that there were two genders
and i was the other one thank you
classified you as other
what do i do coach let's make him kick
her what the hell i don't know lady
send your brother in
uh okay so indigenous people's day was
yesterday and we didn't really feel we
needed to talk about it because i've
done entire segments on this in the past
with native americans the myth of the
horseback riding peace loving culture by
the way we're actually going to have on
the show i should have told you our
cannibal correspondent that's right oh
good okay yeah from the uh the the k uh
the cave uh the kb tribe he survived i
don't know if i'm pronouncing that
correctly uh carob carob character
is it caribou like the carpenter
into the caribbean like caribbean that
makes sense for canadian viewers out
there
can't care but people don't remember
camp caribou that was a great show oh
okay i've got like a ping pong ball
they're like five people who love this
so yesterday was columbus day
five whole people huh five whole people
canadian television before youtube was
just like the bad early youtube videos
really you realize that when youtube
came out i'm like oh it's network
television
i like bad videos i love kids in the
hall though yeah no that wasn't and
everything else was just what is this
it's just well the hockey was good yeah
the hockey was that that's never been
great
they called it in detroit honky
i think that's a little that's what they
really did they really did yeah you'd be
like you playing honky oh well i'm like
i'm not playing honky
start comparing fun
tires i don't know monkey ring talking
about them uh playing so let me move on
with this here so yesterday was there's
more than one black player
there's no other one black player in
hockey i meant on this on the team we
were playing off oh okay yeah yeah no i
don't want to i don't want to throw out
facts we all know that there's tons of
black people in the end so many of them
who do you think invented the knuckle
puck [ __ ]
yeah that's true there's actually more
more blacks on the mighty ducks yeah
there's more blacks in the nhl
and don't you love if anyone anyone who
saw mighty ducks who was keenan thompson
really don't remember yeah like they're
collecting the team back together and
they're like oh my gosh we need to have
a bl so you know they go and pick up one
of the white kids like goldberg working
like anthony's pretzels or something
right like oh we need to do something
that's hockey related for the black kid
in the off season so what they clearly
just did is took a place like in
southern california where they would
have been playing street ball basketball
but instead set up
trash can street hockey yeah like you
just see you're looking at 20 kids
playing 20 black kids playing street
hockey like oh yeah that's where you go
yeah that's where you go for talent what
you don't see pick up hockey games on
the basketball court in harlem what's
wrong with you yeah who doesn't do and
what what about keenan thompson doesn't
scream a hockey player
but not one of us not one of us failed
to attempt the knuckle puck and have it
swipe up and hit us in the eye so thanks
keenan we appreciate it also from my
drunk driving charges it turns out that
uh the punishment of coaching a hockey
team not even an option no it's not
dave tried he's like i know but can i
coach i don't know i'm like i watch this
i'm totally willing
they're like no man wait you're gonna
sentence me to coaching children's
hockey you knew the rules when you set
foot in my courtroom bombay
well no one knows these rules that's
weird also that he did not look like a
bombay no he never did
there's a lot wrong with that movie he
was just trying to get out of the ticket
like what i don't understand i'm gordon
bombay what which used to be mumbai
sorry
it also has the best line in any disney
movie which is blood breath or urine no
thanks i'm full
sorry we went off on mighty ducks let me
back to columbus day and indigenous
people's day uh or as they say in
australia aboriginals right we're not
allowed to say that yeah so i don't even
know why it's indigenous i guess now we
say indigenous we don't say native
americans you don't say indians we grew
up saying aboriginals in canada now they
still say aboriginals in australia we
say indigenous here we don't see native
americans anymore so the whole point is
you were taught a bunch of crap in
school about not only thanksgiving and
we've gone through that you've been
taught a bunch of crap in regards to how
the native americans indigenous used to
live everyone is flawed all societies
come you know they've made some mistakes
especially the ones that raped pillaged
scalped and not scalped in a way to
actually count the kills in war but
scalping women and children alive as a
torture method and cannibalism okay some
of those got away from these tribes just
to let you know
they didn't teach you about that in
school so you would probably if you were
in school believe and you heard of one
in the media talking about this that
columbus this is the reason for
indigenous indigenous people's day
columbus was this raping genocidal
maniac who was racist and i tell you
what
i believed some of these myths yeah even
i believed some of the myths when i'm
like oh that that whole thing is
completely untrue
so uh it's now been acknowledged by joe
biden
uh october 11th it's indigenous people
for people who don't know used to be
columbus day uh
now it's indigenous people's day which
is when you think about the day it's
like okay the man discovered the new
world these people meaning the
indigenous people were all they they
just happened to be here for centuries
and didn't use the wheel i know they
they it was like oh what are you famous
for well we were here when that guy
showed up yeah yeah why don't you just
call it no wheels day yeah yeah and we
all know when joe biden was like
i'm an [ __ ] i'm sorry
look this is long after the roman empire
and the greeks and the ottomans genghis
khan would be like
it's like they didn't use the wheels
they hadn't domesticated horses they
hadn't so this idea we'll even get to
the smallpox blankets yeah what do you
think happens if i cannot go
okay
i
i found out recently that i am highly
allergic to horses do you know how i
knew because i'm never around horses and
then someone said hey would you like to
come horseback riding i said that sounds
fun and then
five minutes of looking like the guy
from the goonies later
there's a problem my eye swells up i'm
unable to breathe i sound like darth
vader without his mask on you need to
get a cpap on me rub vicks vapo rub on
my chest the point is i had not been
exposed to horses i found out very
quickly that they came with pollen
bacteria and dander i wasn't used to
that's exactly what happened when you
had a civilization who had been here
didn't use the wheel for centuries and
for the first time they were actually
introduced to horses you know who else
was allergic to horses
christians for a reef
give it to me you get it i wanted to see
if you could you could drop it off in
hell i know
i just wanted to see if you would get it
oh it's the go-to for paralyzed superman
it is it's a genre superman can't walk
whoever did that but now have you have
you seen the new superman now the story
oh yeah he's buying so you know he would
have get tossed up the horse would have
gone oh
i think he would have been killed by it
while holding onto a fence
don't look that up dude
no no stop look that up we're
joking but i'm not joking but i'm not i
am not just sorry about the native
americans mr hands that native americans
did not use the wheel they had not
domesticated horses anyways saki
fielded uh questions about biden's
decision to change our uh traditions
here in north america yesterday columbus
data indigenous peoples day
people today
well today is both columbus day as of
now and this is why you're asking the
question as well as indigenous uh
people's day i'm not aware of any
discussion of ending that uh either of
ending the the prior federal holiday at
this point uh but i know that uh
recognizing today as indigenous people's
day is something that the president felt
uh strongly about personally he's happy
to be the first president to celebrate
um and to make it um uh the the the
speaker history of moving forward felt
strongly you know that was his urinary
tract infection yes
when he was a boy he learned nothing of
columbus day and how columbus was good
this guy wasn't a okay so look here are
some of the myths we'll just go through
here because right now they want to and
i unders look no one is saying that any
history is flawless okay no we're not
saying of course every single society
has made mistakes what you search
yourself is which society ended up
creating what is best yeah and look i
think that one's pretty cut and dry this
is the the world's only superpower at
any point to not just take over the rest
we could easily do it certainly canada
certainly canada we could have done it
many times over and we don't okay the
united states go and i agree with you
nation building shouldn't be doing
nation building that's a new term that's
basically been created for modern
america you think genghis khan nation
was nation building do you think you
think nero was nation building
do you think the turks were nation
building no they were colonizing that's
a very big difference well it's kind of
i don't understand the nature like this
what is this celebrating national we got
our ass kicked day that's like germany
going hey ve day victory in europe we
want to celebrate that too that's when
you beat us yeah could we be a part of
that
why would you want that i thought you
said vd day and it was a reference to
hitler's stis
victory in europe yeah he had a lot of
them he had a lot of them yeah it was on
meth he had stis and he was like
worshiping all kinds of weird when
people try to say hitler was a christian
it's like oh shut up yeah you don't know
hitler just a crank estimate cranked out
like oh yeah hitler was a christian i
couldn't tell while he was too busy
banging eva braun on testosterone in
front of a ram's head oh yeah no i
thought he's probably somebody who i
yeah he's open i can picture him opening
the pray the hymnal booklet next to me
you rube okay so here's a claim that
probably we have to move on with us that
uh you probably believe that columbus
speaking of hitler committed genocide
that he was just like hitler this was
just echoed yesterday of course i need
to read this because it was uh according
to nba coach see i don't know oh greg
popovich popovich
he initiated
a new world genocide nope wrong that's
what he did
and
beginning with him
and what he said in motion what followed
what was that
the annihilation of every indigenous
person nope and hispaniola no which was
everyone the dominican republic today
and it's it's it's no knock on italian
americans that's a silly argument no one
was taking it as a knock on italian
americans proud of hitler talk about a
straw man like was there a que he's
trying to act like and by the way i'm
just so i'm not saying this to bad
mouthed italians what i'm not saying
that uh you know there's a there's a
black man hiding behind the uh hiding
behind the uh the cabin over there in
sicily somewhere what i'm not saying
that italians are a bunch of greasy what
do you
no one thinks that this is a dig at the
italians that's not the issue that we
have with it let here let me give you my
issue what did they ask him though
do you think you should have kicked that
point let me tell you about columbus
yeah
but it's a basketball coach though let
me read to the definition let me how
little i know too yeah the definition of
genocide hold on this isn't the view
that's not all that it's not all cackle
here in crosstalk
because of you then we sound like
whoopee sorry it's genocide crazy child
i didn't know native americans didn't
have horses that's ridiculous back into
habit
[Laughter]
the definition of genocide is a
systematic and widespread extermination
or attempted extermination of a national
racial religious or ethnic group okay
couple of things first off there are
more people who are one portion insert
tribe today than ever in american
history because a lot of them
intermarried and a lot of them took
these beautiful native american women as
wives and they integrated okay look
this is i i is that considered racist
like oh native american women are
beautiful
a lot of them are i thought we had
pocahontas for a reason yes just saying
yes she can paint she can uh she can
paint with um you know my colors
so just one color
the native americans
also to be clear
wasn't genocide they were
okay let me let me let me bring this up
this is one of those come come again
stupid they say oh wipe them wipe them
out with small pox blankets
centuries before germ theory
if you try to go back into that no nay
if you try to go back in time to a
hundred years after columbus
and explain to someone what a germ was
what a microbe was in a microscope they
burn you they burn you alive they say
you're a witch but we're supposed to
believe that they're waging biological
warfare and the interesting thing is we
have the numbers okay the numbers are of
the estimated 250 000 natives in
hispaniola as that nba as popovich says
uh columbus first stop in the americas
in 1492 new infectious diseases wiped
out a staggering 236 000 indigenous
people by 1517 nearly 95
of their population look for there to be
a genocide there's a debate where people
like i don't know do you have to
actually wipe out you have to be
successful and wipe out a hundred
percent and then sometimes people go
like i don't know maybe as long as it's
90 or it's not really a battle but
they're unarmed and they're you could
still consider that a genocide these are
the sort of discussions that might go on
in the halls of higher learning
never at any other point in history is
it considered a genocide when it's
guaranteed less than five percent
who were murdered right 95
thought they had the sneezes wouldn't
have been a big deal with some clairton
or allegra we didn't know we had no idea
but look stephen they did walk around
without masks right so that is true that
95 counts it just makes common sense
all right uh not to mention look there
and uh when we're talking about the
other five percent
almost every story that you've been
taught about there was a battle where
there were significant casualties on
both sides no matter what green day
tells you okay
so but don't bury your cat in one of
their cemeteries do not no
the point here is you would bring it up
um they also ward before we got here
so look and i understand that
[ __ ] things were committed on all
sides okay yeah let's be clear about
that i'm not absolving all of uh not
just for not just tomorrow for columbus
but if you want to talk about the
pilgrims i'm not saying that there
weren't
acts of ill will committed from all
sides however this idea that it was a
peace loving culture horseback riding
culture that just got wiped out
by the new settlers well look it's not
true and you have to ask yourself why if
it's not true and i'll continue making
the case here as to why it's not true
why if it's not true are they so dead
set on making us believe this in school
well could it be because of
could it be that the basis of western
society the basis of what has become
known to be modern christendom and life
liberty pursuit of happiness the united
states of america i know we can talk
about columbus not setting foot in north
america we can get into all that but my
point remains here if you remove the
basis if you bastardize the basis you
can convince everyone that this whole
country was based on what genocide that
it was based on what slavery like half
the country
didn't fight in a war and huge numbers
of people dying because they thought
that slavery was wrong like republicans
the overlong majority republicans didn't
pass civil rights because it took some
time to get to the ideals that we
claimed that we wrote down an ink when
we wrote down an ink the idea is the
idea that all men are created equal
wasn't an accident they could have
easily said except the blacks they could
have easily said except the uh well back
then they would have written engines
right but except the indigenous right
i'm trying to copy paste what we're
supposed to say they could have easily
done that they didn't this was them
saying all right
market put us to the test we've got to
get there eventually we've got to get to
this point eventually because they left
a place where it wasn't even close
wasn't even close when you look at the
rest of the world there's still slavery
going on there's still genocide going on
today okay so here's the thing native
americans also committed bloody acts of
war against each other uh historian
bernard balin wrote
the natives were always involved in
warfare partly because life would become
imbalanced in a way that needed
justification and response and reprisal
and reprisals within their lives are
very important um there are also a lot
of natives who wanted europeans to be
here yeah yeah look look look i'm not
really going with the show map here okay
all right let's not even talk about
columbus i'll get back to columbus but
uh let's go to okay the aztecs the
mayans right rolling heads down pyramids
you all know what's going on okay
pulling out still beating hearts wiping
barrows on the backs of frogs you all
like them world's ending in 2012 yes
exactly yes so shitty john cusack film
you got it that was good
okay it was not it was so good it was
good you know people here you guys know
who the conquistadors are yeah yeah okay
conquistadors yeah how many
conquistadors were there in this room
that's a trick a few hundred that's it
yes it was a few hundred conquistadors
okay
there weren't that many now how do you
think they conquered the many many many
thousands i don't know the numbers in
front of me i'm willing to get tens of
thousands
of thousands yes how do you think they
managed to conquer them
there were so many natives
okay let me back up a little bit
the mayans had a lot of gold
yeah did you guys know this i did yeah
they had a lot of gold they had entire
temples entire
structures filled with gold they had
gold that could left last generations
and generations and generations and they
had been moved into nice big piles how
do you think let me ask you this how do
you think they procured said gold
they
i'll give you a hint it relates to why
all the people who are enslaved by the
gold-wielding [ __ ] sided with a few
hundred conquistadors they couldn't have
won a war or a genocide if they wanted
to it was a bunch of natives who said
we're tired of being enslaved and
watching our women being raped unless we
collect gold we feel like we they tell
us that we they tell us that we have two
options right option one is go collect
gold or number two is they kill us
unless we collect gold we don't really
feel like those are legitimate options
so man in the tin hat and funny red
beard can you help us out right and
they're like hey conquistadors are here
how perfect you guys stacked our gold
for us right
put it all in one place we put a little
bug in their ear gave them some fire
water and let them take care of it
they can't hold their liquor
okay
knew that then so here's another myth
that you're taught in school this is a
very specific one that columbus himself
uh was a renowned rapist uh-oh is he
getting me too while he initially
described the native americans as kind
and peaceful columbus had no problem
with his men raping and killing them
there are horrific accounts of columbus
selling native american women and young
girls along with brutal stories of his
men killing and torturing native people
and even babies for fun if you decide to
look into it proceed with caution yeah i
did
well i did look into it here's the thing
i was also taught this in school yeah
it's not sure is this i don't know it's
mtv something
they're about to play
yeah the algorithm i wanted to watch
monsters inc what's dick or dildo
so
look
this is this is they're really they're
when you same thing when people talk
about the bible okay they say well there
are all these other books why weren't
these books included it's actually
pretty easy to understand apostolicity
right this is the standard is were these
people who were around directly at the
time of jesus christ were they
consistent with each other and or or
kind of they could be separated that
they knew a direct apostle right that's
kind of why they're included because
there were some random books of people
who wanted to get in on that christ
action saying there were flying unicorns
and stuff and people like all right this
is incongruent with the rest that we
have it's not some anti-christian jewish
conspiracy theory okay let's be really
clear about it if you read the dead sea
scrolls there's actually not that much
to figure out there outside of
understanding and having some insight
into another jewish sect uh that existed
sort of autonomously from christ kind of
interesting to see sort of their
messianic figureheads and what they
believed even though they were separated
from the point is look there's a reason
that we picked those books in the bible
okay
it's were these written contem were they
contemporary yeah with jesus or were
they contemporaries with the people who
were there with jesus here's what you
need to understand when they're talking
about columbus being a rapist it comes
from two sources two i looked into it
two being the number of sources the only
number of sources referring to him as
murdering children for fun being two now
let me and by the way the first one
comes from uh michelle de cuneo and uh
it's not even the original letter
okay let's be clear about this michelle
de canelo was actually uh basically a
lying frat boy aristocrat and how do you
know that he made this stuff up well he
talked about temples in the caribbean
were nonexistent he made up things that
could be verified as factually false and
they were and then he said oh and yeah
columbus raped somebody he had an axe to
grind with columbus this was very clear
and he was wrong about a lot of other
things that he wrote for some reason we
don't do the same vetting when it comes
to columbus being a rapist uh the other
one rose mcgowan yeah
um
oh he also said by the way this guy he
said that he captured a careeb girl and
that she was given to him by columbus
stuff that is verifiably false he was a
compulsive liar um
the other rumors of rape and this
brutality they come from a political
enemy of columbus fernando i hoping in
this right baba dia baba dia howard
streams penis so baba dia actually
wanted to be governor himself
his writing he only interviewed rebels
who were unhappy with columbus he
arrested columbus and his brothers he
seized all his assets he he replaced him
this was basically what you would
consider a coup so in other words the
only two sources that that make these
claims
are verifiably unreliable sources and
the point here is
these historians who decide what the
curriculum is with your children are
they applying they're vetting yeah and
the determination of the veracity of
their sources are they applying the
standards equally yeah well it's it's
basically like the same it's like
christine blasey ford's story coming i
did happen somewhere back in the day
somehow i know something happened yeah
right and some somebody was raped it's
like the guy like yeah he totally told
the therapist isn't the same as what you
told the washington post and that's not
the same with the fbi think and that
house doesn't exist yeah but maybe it
does
okay
that's the retort it's the temple and no
there's no temples on the island but
there's got to be a temple there's got i
i know i thought i remembered one no
oh well oh well you'll still be teaching
this to second graders for the rest of
eternity of course yes yeah yeah so um
another truth another thing is this was
also in direct opposition to columbus's
letter so these are just this is hearsay
from people who wanted guitar and
feather columbus not saying he was
perfect i'm saying this idea now that
has been widely accepted that he was a
genocidal maniac who raped and killed
for fun is not true likely very similar
to a lot of people flawed churchill
necessary yes cheat on his wife probably
abraham lincoln a lot of people
necessary yes did he make some mistakes
sure have a crazy ass wife absolutely
okay so uh in his own letter from
columbus he actually ordered his men to
stay away from native women this is from
his journal this is from his journal
okay keep in mind this wasn't a this
wasn't a press release yeah
in other words he didn't expect someone
outside of maybe his like if he had a
little brother on the ship to read it uh
i have given the men orders not to take
anything from them against their will
so they have paid them for everything i
cannot believe that any man has ever met
a people so good-hearted and generous
referring to the natives so gentle that
they did their utmost to give us
everything they had uh he also made sure
that his men observed three mon uh three
vows of poverty chastity obedience this
was part of the practice this was part
of the code of ethics among his men did
some of them break it i'm sure they did
yeah absolutely but i mean this is also
i mean think about the time period that
we're talking about too for these guys
to have any kind of care for the people
that they find in the land that they're
going to kind of conquer or trade with
like this is what happens you go in you
wipe the people out you take what's
theirs and you call it your own that's
what people were doing at this time for
these people to go and be like hey don't
take anything from them unless you give
them something in return they could have
taken the island it's an island it's a
beautiful place no we talked about this
last i think last year the island of
manhattan yeah that's remember i don't
remember the exact so you guys can go
well you can't search it but if you
search it on mug club right if you join
my club you can search it a lot of
people don't know this the island of
manhattan it was the canary seat you
know canarsie brooklyn it comes from the
carnegie trail there was another trip in
manhattan i don't remember the name
escapes me basically settlers came in
they said uh hey we think we could do a
lot with this island of manhattan back
then because the natives they were
basically landlocked and it was it was a
real pain in the ass it was like all of
manhattan was like roosevelt island
today right you didn't really want to be
there there was only one way in and out
and when you had a rowboat it took quite
a while sorry kayak was seal skins which
we won't even talk about how they club
seals because that's a sensitive topic
for the left and we try to ignore it my
point
is we move on here okay so they said
look do you guys have crappy boats and
you don't want to be on this island so
we would like to buy it the natives said
oh how and they said well we'll pay you
for it and they said oh i said we'll pay
you for it now what they did is they
paid them 30 guilders i believe worth
and this was some something like 10 000
beaver pelts you're talking about i
don't know how many times they pay them
price they paid a price for it they
moved into manhattan then manhattan
started becoming what you know as new
york of course it was more uh you know
you talk about more farmland initially
and then became more urbanized and the
canarsie came back like oh whoa we like
what you've done with the place we think
we'll stay like no no no no no that's
not how this works they didn't
understand the concept of personal
property and the finality of an
agreement
you know look anywhere else anywhere
else when someone is holding somebody
for ransom or in a hostage situation
yeah do you if you're planning a double
cross do you pay them the money and
allow them to leave
that's what happened with manhattan and
when they came back they still didn't
bring back the money right well no you
show up with a supreme nephews
well you show up with superior
technology you take a look around and
you're like huh
we can you got wheels
what is that uh what what do you mean
what is that that you're rolling oh yeah
it's just actually a slightly smooth
stone like you've been seeing since the
beginning of time there's one and
there's one that never dawned on you no
but by the way the god of the rocks made
them that way we didn't want to
offend them yeah hey where are we going
we're taking it all tom yeah okay
just look around and you're like this is
ours now that's what happened hey whoa
you can travel much faster than my
nephew one bear running yes cause he's
on a horse
what is this four-legged okay so here's
another myth we gotta get through this
and we have our our cannibal
correspondent uh
the myth is that the natives were
peaceful that columbus showed up and
that he terrorized them that before them
before uh columbus that they were i've
kind of already been through this uh
look there were there were two main
tribes when we were talking about what's
been going on here and people talk about
him uh there's a civic story i remember
being taught in school they said he took
their weapons and their bows and arrows
and this kind of thing and disarmed them
okay
there were two main tribes there were
the arrow acts and they were the um the
caribs like caribbean i think that's
pronounced um who were
vicious vicious cannibals to be clear
now the arawaks didn't have as advanced
weapons like they had stuff they didn't
really have advanced weapons and when uh
columbus came ashore they're like oh no
cannibals so they started getting really
paranoid they came in they talked like
oh my what are you talking about we
thought you were the cannibals like what
they're cannibals are and they go yeah
they really they have these great bows
and weapons and so then of course there
was war with the people who were
cannibalizing the arrow wax and saying
all right you guys don't get to have bow
and arrows anymore on account that you
keep eating people
we don't like that it's not a good thing
that seems like a good charge it was
weird though at the time the arrowheads
round
yeah it doesn't make a lot of sense yeah
but not the wheel no wheel no wheel but
round knocks them out so they can eat
them while you're alive yeah so this is
just doesn't that change the context a
little bit it's like hold on a second
why do you think that there was trading
with some natives and not with others
cannibalism that was one of the deciding
factors yes it was
some would say that's at the top of the
list some would say it is at the top of
the list it's like huh
these guys are cool and we're trading
with them and these guys
you get a little fire water and they eat
you yeah well man's face i don't really
think that we want to uh do a deal with
you why because you ate john smith and
you shivered that weeping willow in the
eye we think that uh i'm gonna keep
moving down the trail and i know john
smith was way later on the point just
shut up
there was a casserole right there yes
there was a little ride there you had
all kinds of food you walked right past
that and ate the fat guy i mean you
killed him in eight yeah he was still
alive
bob was moaning
his name was that's another i don't have
this in front look i don't give a rats
that's what we have as far as people
know people say actually where did you
think they learned to scalp
very very different europeans used to
here's what they used to they used to
cut off heads because they didn't have
dog tags back then they didn't have they
didn't have
no seriously they didn't have modern
technology to get a head count of how
many people they killed in war so they
used to cut off heads and go back to the
battlefield with the wheelbarrow they
said say okay scalps will save space
right then we got the dog tags and now i
don't know it's like sitting outside of
mcdonald's and watching the numbers
change with how much the military spends
on this [ __ ] but the point is back then
that's why europeans use scalping yeah
it's not the same certain native
american tribes we use the same term
scalping they would do it to people
alive as a torture and intimidation
method it wasn't to count who they had
conquered in battle
does that change the context
all right so anyway but look in the
spirit of full disclosure before we go
to mug club we always try to provide
some uh some balance here yeah and uh we
need both sides of the issue so we're
actually going to go live now to our uh
kharibe cannibal correspondent
[Music]
all right please welcome uh the leader
of the uh carob's native i keep know if
it's is it
korea is it caribou
ask him i don't know
uh chief eldorado neighbor belly is it
carobs or caribs karib okay thank you
well thank you for uh being here sir how
white men
thank you for having me craw daddy son
oh okay well thank you that's not my
name but i i understand that you feel
there are some misconceptions out there
that you would like to clear up yes
there are a lot of misinformation about
their about us a lot of fake nasa uk out
there fake nasa i don't um that's how we
say fake news stephen oh okay
so um from what i understand primarily
you want to correct
the record on cannibalism
well no we hate people
but that's not all we did okay so then
the question is what else did you do we
gathered we hunted okay uh what did you
what did you hunt what did you hunt
primarily that's beside the point
stephen
i don't know i don't really know if
that's we met them we made teepees we
tan the hides with the thing uh-huh yeah
and we did a lot of outreach stephen
outreach okay so what kind of outreach
did you do well you know we'd get
involved in the local community we'd
reach out
then we'd eat them oh okay well couldn't
you have just
see this is the thing we're trying to
say it's uh
like couldn't even just for example
eaten animals
well
i ate a bear once
really
once
too gamey we mainly wore the animals for
clothes yeah i see that uh animals lives
are sacred and of course and you know
the wind colors all that yes the wind
colors all that uh yeah let me ask this
do you ever eat members of your own
tribe
no we're not animals
though they're sacred of course they're
sacred we ate the airwalks okay but did
you ever like uh maybe accident did you
ever mistake uh kharib for an arawak
oh no all the time
i once accidentally ate my son-in-law
okay all right so then that he didn't he
said no but he made it sounds like he
actually meant yes okay we're out of
time all right thank you wait wait wait
i just wanted to say that from now on
the carib tribe are officially no longer
cannibals okay well that's very good
as a matter of fact since going paleo
i've changed my life okay chief and you
can subscribe to my podcast from
cannibal to caveman on spotify all right
chief nickel bottom or something
[Music]
all right one uh one last semester for
me to go through here before we leave
and i want to know which one of these
you were taught in school uh i was
talking genocide in school i was taught
the small that that the whole reason
they died
blankets the wiped out like popovich
said taught that i was taught in school
granted this was canadian school and i
don't know if this i don't know that
this one is taught in school but that
really a lot of people believe that uh
you know columbus went around to to
prove that the earth was flat
oh yes
did you remember that so that was
something that used to be taught i guess
maybe now it's been so debunked that
maybe they're not making that claim
doesn't make any sense like what would
he do like i'm going to sail off of the
earth to prove to you that it is flat so
if i never come back yeah i was right
little did he know there were some
cannibals waiting for him on the edge
we actually learned that it was to prove
that the earth was uh round yeah they
got here and then they had a meal with
the indians and everybody lived in peace
honestly that's what we learned yeah we
were little kids
here's the thing too which was fine i
actually put a picture of me on
instagram wearing an indian
uh headdress when i was like 10. we just
did it again um
so yeah so there was a myth native
there's this myth that people want you
to believe right because i'll often
throw this out and i know that there are
some silly flat earthers out there and
there's such a small percent it's like
the westboro baptist church look they
have 12 members and nine of them are
cousins they have flippers for legs okay
let's be really clear about that but
they get more air time like flat
earthers the helicopter goes up and okay
look whatever just shut up move
volcanoes and okay good do you do your
thing this isn't a show
that being said it's a very very very
small percentage of people tiny less
than a percentage point of a percentage
when you're talking about people who
actually believe it and it was never
mainstream you can go all the way back
to the greeks and they believe that the
earth was round so this idea that
columbus now why do they say that
because they want you to say really was
there was uh was west what became known
as western civilization was it really
more civilized when you look at the
natives and how advanced they were and
columbus thought the uh you know these
people thought the earth was flat no
it's not true the goal to this is to try
and undercut the foundations of the
society which by the way
is the best place today in the world for
former spaniards former italians
whatever that popovich guy was to i
don't know what exactly what he was
talking about and current native
americans here in the united states we
have more people with a fraction of
current native american blood for
growing uh johnny depp claims it right
everyone claims partially native
american elizabeth warren yeah yeah
she is yeah and her 23andme said shut
the hell up i already told you no
no you will a little her 23 news a white
sheet of paper sent back
and there was a tiny little dot in the
bottom right hand corner that's that's
what you get right yeah and then it was
just a bill for the pow wow ciao book
from the local chippewa tribe all right
we'll be taking our commission
thank you thank you you lying
appropriating wench everything about her
is a lie and most of what you learned
about columbus is a lie and most of what
you've learned about the election as far
as you being in this crazy minority in
just thinking that maybe it wasn't the
most secure and safe election of all
time with mass mail and voting uh of
course which had never occurred on that
scale going against the state
constitution they want you to think that
hey you're alone no one else believes
that that's a lie what you've learned
about columbus is a lie and that you've
been taught uh that elizabeth warren uh
is is one 19th cherokee and warrants her
writing pow wow chow is a lie as well
the point is you don't trust your
institutions and guess what a lot of the
media they want to blame you i don't
blame you at all i blame them i blame
them right now for this football bull
crap i blame them for indigenous
people's day and i blame the educational
establishment and i blame them for
letting elizabeth warren get away for
years to the point where she had a
best-selling book about native american
cooking despite not being native
american for the same reason i blame
them for not calling illinois on
marrying and banging her brother find me
one example of her denying it and i will
issue a correction for which you can
admonish me next week but right now
we're about to go watch the uh we'll do
a review
of the fouchy film we all stayed up and
watched it on disney plus
and we'll take your chat
at mug club liverpool.com club youtube
thank you um i don't think you want to
be here anyway piss off
[Music]
bye